I'm so happy to do this for editors  because we acknowledge directors so many  times in our industry but as any  director will say the editor is your is  your gold and as an actor we so  appreciate you for scouring through  everything to find that little moment  that performance so that's to all  editors I want to say thank you anvi  Coates is not a great female director  editor she is a great great editor she's  not a trailblazer for women she's a  trailblazer for all of us and has left  her mark on some of the greatest films  of all time films that are simply not  just displays of virtuoso editing but  also landmarks in the evolution of  storytelling in film